hey it's evan i'm at home and today i
wanted to share with you a few
things from my alternative lifestyle
that have really helped
my body a little bit different video
than usual but
it's really helped me and so i thought
i'd make a video to help you potentially
as well
the first thing is uh is my shoes so i'm
here in the hallway i'm going to
open up my closet you can see i'm i'm
barefoot here
my favorite shoes as i open up here let
me pull them out
are my vibram five toe shoes
i used to have uh really bad knees i
don't know why my knees
were always really bad i used to have to
rub them to to get them from not feeling
i don't know they felt weird i used to
just have all these problems with my
knees i went to
a chiropractor i used to have insoles in
my
in my feet all the time and it kept
changing it up and i'm like in my 20s
right
i'm in my 20s and i guess in late teens
in high school too
and i should not be having these
problems right but my shoes were causing
me issues
and they thought the answer were insoles
what really helped me
was going with these vibram
five-toed shoes so it's basically like
walking barefoot you're supposed to be
walking barefoot in your life it it uh
it's the best thing for you so when i'm
at home
i am walking barefoot and uh at the
office too i was walking barefoot
with socks on obviously and then i have
my vibram five toe shoes that i try to
wear
as much as possible and it takes a while
to get used to you can't just wear them
all at once right away it takes some
training you wear them for half an hour
then an hour then two hours and
you slowly get used to it but after
doing that my knee problems
gone no problems at all with my knees
anymore so
thank you viber next
we're going to the kitchen say hi to the
minions
we're going into my home office and
the next thing is the stand-up desk so
i'm all set up here for video day we've
got actually two computers now because
nina likes to play league of legends so
we uh
we can play next to each other and get
some league of legends going on at night
here's my setup i've got my microphone
i've got my mickey mouse
glass of water and my smoothie to drink
this stand-up desk really helped solve
my back issues i had really bad
back issues let me flip this thing
around so you can see me
i had really bad back issues so bad just
crazy pain and again seeing
chiropractors
and i remember in university having to
go
uh weekly and have these electric nodes
put on my back and he put
shocks through it and he would crack my
back and that stuff adds up
it's really expensive and and i'm in
university right like i'm supposed to be
healthy here
why is my back hurting so much and it
was from sitting down too much you know
i
i do a lot of work in front of the
computer my business is mostly in front
of the computer
the company i had at the time it was a
software company so it was always in
front of the computer
and and i would slouch and and it was
just bad for my back
and i slowly moved to a stand-up desk so
it takes a while again to get used to
you can't just stand up all day
but you could train yourself and you can
build it up you can create it yourself
you have to go and spend tons of money
to create a stand-up desk
but it really helps solve all of my back
issues
so try stand-up desk there's tons of
health benefits for you
it is a little alternative i remember
people coming to the office
there's nowhere for them to sit at a
regular meeting because i don't have
chairs so that's a little awkward but i
guess you can always get a boardroom or
something too
so try stand up desk really help solve
my back one last thing i want to talk
about and this is the newest one
my neck so we're going to
the bedroom so here's my bed
and i still got bad neck problems i had
bad knees bad back and bad neck
and what i found was by not using a
pillow i could solve
my neck issues by sleeping on my back
and not using a pillow
so this is our bed there's nina has a
pillow and i don't have a pillow
there's a little blue thing at the back
there's a face mask to kind of block out
the sun
in the morning but i've always been a
stomach sleeper
i've always been a stomach sleeper and
it just you know killed my neck
and sleeping on the pillow killed my
neck and so i found that using a memory
foam mattress
really helped me be able to sleep on my
back and not using a pillow really help
my neck
so here i am now how old am i it's 2014
i'm 34 years old
my knees feel better my back feels
better my neck feels better
than when i was in high school and
university
and it's all because of the vibrant
shoes the stand-up desk and not sleeping
with a pillow none of these things cost
a lot
but have a major impact at least on my
life and hopefully on yours
if you like this video let me know leave
a comment below you can click the
the link in the description to support
me and if you guys have
alternative things that you do leave it
in the comments i want to see them
because i'm all about
experimenting and trying new things life
hacks to make life better so let me know
in the comments
you can click on my face at the top
corner top corner whichever way it is
to subscribe to the channel thank you so
much and i'll see you soon